vor der abstimmung über die
geschäftsordnung wird von der fraktion
der afd
das wort zur geschäftsordnung gewünscht
das wort ja der abgeordnete dr baumann
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
wir leben heute eine einmalige situation
in diesem haus die abgeordneten des
bundestages sollen ein gesetz zustimmen
bei dem der wissenschaftliche dienst des
bundestages selbst befürchtet offiziell
dass es verfassungswidrig ist zudem auch
ein bundestags- vizepräsident sagt diese
denkweise kannten wir bisher nur aus
autoritären staaten
meine damen und herren so können wir
hier nicht vorgehen das gesetz muss
überarbeitet werden
wir beantragen die rücküberweisung in
die ausschüsse es muss runter von dieser
tage so hat meine damen und herren
wenn die regierung plant unglaubliche in
der republik nie dagewesene
einschränkungen der freiheit nicht nur
schul und geschäftsschließungen sondern
auch strenge ausgangssperren die leute
werden praktisch in ihren wohnungen
eingesperrt hausarrest und alles bloß
gestützt auf kaum aussagekräftige
inzidenz werte dafür davor warnen jetzt
davor waren jetzt auch zahlreiche staats
und verfassungsrechtler wie kirchhoff
es sei so wörtlich verfassungsrechtlich
dringend angezeigt andere parameter zu
berücksichtigen meine damen und herren
wohl tut die bundesregierung das nicht
dass es angezeigt in dieser sache wir
kritisieren dabei nicht nur den inhalt
wie kritisieren auch die art und weise
wie das hier durchgeschleust wird erst
vorgestern kam das gesetz zur beratung
in die wichtigen ausschüsse oft erst
nach sitzungsbeginn frau hast du dann
hören sie doch zu zu geschäfts aber noch
erst nach sitzungsbeginn kam das in die
ausschüsse präsentierte die regierung
dann aber plötzlich änderungsanträge in
den ausschusssitzungen 84 änderungen auf
12 eng beschriebenen seiten
niemand konnte das lesen geschweige denn
verstehen worüber er sofort als
abgeordneter abschreiben sollte
schlimmer noch die regierungsfraktionen
hatten das gesetz schon in der
vergangenen woche durchs parlament
peitschen wollen ohne die geltenden
fristen einzuhalten
aber die afg hatte als einzige fraktion
keinen frist verzicht für die plenums
aussetzung erteilt weil sonst das ganze
noch mehr zur farce geworden wäre meine
damen und herren
wieder einmal war die afg die einzige
opposition in diesem haus und was noch
dazu kommt was noch dazukommt stadt in
dieser krise vernünftig zu regieren
beschäftigen die unionsparteien sich vor
allem mit sich selbst
mit korruption und massengeschäft und
ungezügelt händen gebaut man jetzt
kriegen sie nicht zur geschäftsordnung
und hat meistens richtig schließlich uns
die geschäftsführung und wenn sie doch
nur ich komme zum schluss herr präsident
vielen dank wenn sie doch nur halb so
viel energie für unser land aufbringen
müssten müssen uns nicht mit
unausgegorenen gesetzen hierüber fassen
die das fassung des verfassungsgerichts
sowieso zurückziehen wird man dann
klären
so also dieser antrag zur tagesordnung
den hier der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer für die fdp-fraktion
werde baumann formuliert hat und für die
koalitionsfraktionen hören wir jetzt
eben auch einen parlamentarischen
geschäftsführer stefan müller für die
cdu csu fraktion präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen baumann den
eindruck ich würde mich würde mal
interessieren halten sie eigentlich
immer die gleiche um 7 uhr die gleiche
vorlage bei ihren reden weil sie immer
die gleichen reden hier auch erhalten
immer ist es der erstmalige der
einmalige vorgang den wir hier erleben
das ist doch nicht mehr glaubwürdig und
ich will ganz deutlich sagen wir werden
den antrag der fdp ablehnen es ist gut
dass wir dieses gesetz heute beraten und
hier auch beschließen aus drei gründen
erstens das verfahren ist nicht zu
beanstanden es hat alles so
stattgefunden wie es unsere
geschäftsordnung vorsieht es gab eine
erste lesung zu diesem gesetz hier im
haus und eine debatte entsprechend es
gab beratungen in den zuständigen
ausschüssen es gab eine
sachverständigenanhörung und es gab dann
auch in der tat eine ganze reihe von
änderungsanträgen sowie es völlig normal
ist dass wir in einem parlamentarischen
verfahren auch gesetze abändern und es
gibt heute diese abschließende beratung
ohne auf irgendeine der vorgesehenen
fristen zu verzichten sondern alles im
rahmen dessen wie es unsere
geschäftsordnung vorgibt der erste grund
weswegen wir ihren antrag ablehnt der
zweite grund ist da natürlich war die
beratungszeit ambitioniert aber es war
machbar
und ja
es war nämlich offensichtlich deswegen
auch machbar weil es
oppositionsfraktionen gibt die es
tatsächlich hingebracht haben enormes
anträge zu formulieren also
offensichtlich sind sie nicht in der
lage änderungen zu formulieren
im gegensatz zu anderen
oppositionsfraktionen geht es dahin
gekommen
vielleicht befehligen mal einen kurs in
fast reading oder wie das heißt
vielleicht ist das dann eine hilfe aber
wenn sie es nicht fertig bringen die
anträge entsprechend zu lesen dass doch
das nicht das problem von allen anderen
fraktionen in diesem aus liebe
kolleginnen zu nehmen so die wahrheit
ist doch eine völlig andere warum sie
das hier veranstalten
sie wollen sich einschleifen bei
denjenigen die heute noch diese pandemie
leugnen röcke von der afg sagt diese
pandemie ist doch nur herbei getestet da
fällt einem nichts mehr dazu ein
damit befindet er hat sich aber
interessanterweise auf linie der
staatspräsidenten von turkmenistan eines
der abgeschotteten und repressivsten
länder auf dieser erde offensichtlich
fühlen sie sich in diesen systemen aber
sehr wohl verdient und auch sie darf ich
bitten sich auf einen beitrag zur
geschäftsordnung typischen oder dritte
punkt herr präsident weswegen wir diesen
antrag zur geschäftsordnung ablehnen ist
es ist notwendig dass wir dieses gesetz
wir schließen die lage wird jeden tag
gespannter angespannter die
infektionszahlen geruch die
intensivstationen sind voll das hat auch
der präsident der intensivmediziner herr
professor max uns bestätigt es ist jetzt
keine zeit für wissenschaftliche und
politische diskussionen sagt er
jetzt ist höchste zeit zu handeln
jetzt ist krise und alles weitere ideen
ist nichts hinzuzufügen wenn das uns die
intensivmediziner sagen ist es
jedenfalls für uns ein wichtiges
kriterium dafür auch zur handel und
jetzt dafür die grundlage zu legen damit
dieses gesetz in kraft treten kann
so jetzt wird über den
geschäftsordnungsantrag der afd
das gesetz nicht zu lesen sondern die
ausschuss dazu überweisen noch nicht
abgestimmt verzeihung war ich etwas
voreiliges spricht noch der
geschäftsführer der parlamentarisch der
fdp-fraktion und waren zunächst nur zwei
geschäftsführer angekündigt herr
präsident meine sehr geehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen wird
diskutieren heute über eine änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes und da gibt es
einmal eine debatte in der sache die
kommt gleich und es gibt eine debatte
zum verfahren die führen wir jetzt in
der sache ist meine fraktion sehr
kritisch das wissen sie wir haben
änderungsanträge vorgelegt wenn die
nicht angenommen werden werden wir das
gesetz ablehnen und eine ganze reihe
meiner kolleginnen und kollegen werden
dann nach karlsburg vors
bundesverfassungsgericht ziehen in der
sache sind wir sehr kritisch aber darum
geht es jetzt nicht es geht um das
verfahren und da kann ich sie als
vertreter gerade einer sehr kritischen
aber am ende auch konstruktive
oppositionspartei aus drei gründen nur
bieten diesen änderungsantrag abzulehnen
das erste argument wir haben uns immer
dafür eingesetzt dass das parlament eine
zentrale rolle bei der pandemie
bekämpfung übernehmen muss denn es geht
um grundrechte und freiheit
und das argument dass uns da immer
entgegen gehalten wurde war
der bundestag kann ja nicht zügig
beraten wir haben in diesem verfahren
gezeigt dass unter einhaltung aller
fristen und auch unter einhaltung aller
minderheitenrechte ein zügiges verfahren
möglich ist und wer jetzt behauptet das
sei schlecht er steckt die gegner des
parlaments und als selbstbewusste
abgeordnete sollten wir nicht die gegner
des parlaments stärken und wasser auf
ihre mühlen schütten wir sollten das
parlament stark meine damen und herren
das zweite argument ist ja es geht um
schwierige fragen es geht um komplexe
instrumente
sie sind schwierig und komplex aber ja
nicht neu jedes der eingesetzten
instrumente ist dem parlament spätestens
seit dem beschluss von 28 a
infektionsschutzgesetz bekannt wir haben
in unserer fraktion laufend begleitet
wie sich das in den ländern auswirkt was
die rechtsprechung was die wissenschaft
hat so sagt und wenn man seine arbeit so
ordentlich macht dann ist es auch
möglich sich eine meinung zu diesen
themen zu bilden und wenn sie das nicht
hinbekommen dann ist das ihr problem und
nicht als problem dieses parlament und
ich komme zu meinem dritten argument und
das ist wahrscheinlich das gewichtigste
herr baumann sie haben ja jetzt durch
ihren verfahrens antrag folgendes
bekundet dass er alles so schwierig das
ging alles so schnell wir können uns
dazu eigentlich keine klare meinung
bilden und im verfahren selber sagen sie
aber sie haben eine ganz klare meinung
über all den social media über kann ich
das lesen wissen sie im deutschen gibt
es einen begriff dafür wenn das reden
zum verfahren und das handeln im
verfahren so auseinanderfallen
wissen sie wie man das nennt im
deutschen wenn reden und handeln so
auseinander fällt
das nennt man heuchelei und die menschen
in deutschland haben keine heuchelei
verdienst und heuchelei partie auch
keinen platz meine damen und herren
carsten schneider spd hat jetzt das wort
zur geschäftsordnung ja und die regel
der parlamentarischen geschäftsführer
geht damit weiter für die
sozialdemokraten carsten schneider
herr präsident die kolleginnen und
kollegen der deutsche bundestag hat der
oder die fraktionen von cdu/csu der spd
haben der vergangenen sitzungswoche den
änderungs anderen gesetzentwurf
eingebracht um die bundes bremse für die
partie lage in deutschland in zum gesetz
zu machen
wir hatten beratungen dazu in den
ausschüssen wir hatten eine anhörung am
freitag haben das wochenende verhandelt
weil sie dass die afb da gemacht hat
sie hat genügend zeit sich den
gesetzentwurf durch zu lesen und die
zeit drängt
wir sind in einer entscheidenden phase
der pandemie in der dritten welle jedes
geschwindigkeit steigt jetzt geht es
darum dass wir die incidents werte nach
unten kriegen wir brauchen sicherheit
wir brauchen dieses gesetz als bundesrat
bremse weil einige länder und in diesem
land leider dies nicht umgesetzt haben
von daher
es gab genügend zeit in der sache sich
damit zu beschäftigen er kollege
buschmann hat ausgeführt dass die fdp
eine klare meinung hat es gibt die
kontakt war gar nicht okay herr kollege
matt ausgeführt es gab genügend zeit auf
änderungsanträge zu stellen
auch das gehört zu einer demokratie dazu
und es gehört auch zu den demonstranten
hier draußen gesagt gehört auch dazu
dass er entschieden dort und wir wollen
diese entscheidung heute haben wir sind
da überhaupt von überzeugt dass
sozialdemokraten ist es notwendig ist
ein starkes gesetz zu machen das uns
dabei hilft diese pandemie den letzten
metern zu besiegen
dafür wollen wir den weg frei machen die
debatte beginnt mit dem zustimmung
finden
[Applaus]
nächster redner so geschäfts und willig
der kollege jan korte die linke
er konnte ebenfalls der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer in dem fall der in
linksfraktion kolleginnen und kollegen
das verfahren was hier gewählt wo das
schon der geschäftsordnung gedeckt es
ist trotzdem politisch nicht klug wie
das ganze gelaufen ist denn dass wir das
wort in diesem tempo hier beschließen
müssen hat etwas mit dem vollständigen
scheitern der politik der
bundesregierung zu tun sonst wären wir
nicht in dieser situation das musste
ausgesprochen werden
nichtsdestotrotz liebe kollegen und
kollegen sind alle fraktionen bis auf
ihre in der lage innerhalb vom
wochenende weiß nicht ob sie da auf
irgendwelchen querdenker demos rumhängen
oder was weiß ich
diese anträge zu prüfen und sich eine
meinung zu bilden sie sind dazu nicht in
der lage ich frage mich was hier
überhaupt wollen wir werden als linker
dieses gesetz ablehnen aus inhaltlichen
gründen weil dort die unternehmerinnen
und unternehmer mit samthandschuhen
angefasst werden und bei anderen gibt es
schwerste einschränkungen das völlig
inakzeptabel
aber das verfahren was hier gewählt
wurde ist nicht gut aber es ist zulässig
und jetzt will ich zu ihnen dann doch
noch mal eine anmerkung machen
sie sitzen ja hier in ihrer ganzen braun
pracht ohne masken bewusst da will ich
ihnen mal sagen und ich frage mich die
klagen gegen den bundestag wegen der
massen pflicht und sie mal nur weil sie
abgeordnete sind müssen sie sich nicht
so verhalten wie der rest der menschen
die morgens mit masken der u bahn sitzen
sie sind nichts besseres und dass jemand
so lange warten
und ich frage mich bei ihnen schon es
sind über 80.000 leute mittlerweile ein
qubit 19 gestorben
es sind jeden tag pflegekräfte die sich
im wahrsten sinne des wortes in ihrer
gesundheit schuften herr quali darum so
die eigentlich diese logik hoffe sie den
mal ins gesicht wenn diktieren braunen
klamauk hierher kollegen daneben was
sagen sie eigentlich diesen menschen da
hat alles im blick gegen den präsidenten
zu bitte sprechen sie zur
geschäftsordnung wenn sie zur
geschäftsordnung fertig sind dann bmg
auf ihren bald heute die geo debatte in
die politische debatte einbetten damit
alle dasteht wie dem auch sei bei der
geschäftsordnung wir werden ihren antrag
volle kanne ablehnen das ist auf jeden
fall ganz sicher und was sie ihr auftrag
gott bewahre uns davor dass sie
irgendwas zu sagen haben in diesem land
in die höhe geschossen
hallo und letzte
die übrigen zwingen sie mich jetzt zu
sagen dass die regel im haus so sind
dass er nicht mein mund nasen abdeckung
tragen muss wenn man nicht unter wahrung
des abstands geburtsland seinem platz
sitzt
danach ist es eine freiwillige
entscheidung aller abgeordneten haben
sich keine verpflichtung dazu füge ich
die zweite bemerkung gleich hinzu liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die sie keine
sitzplätze gefunden haben wir haben
extra schon seit dem frühjahr
vergangenen jahres die korona pandemie
betrifft ja auch uns betrifft sie nicht
so hart wie unsere mitbürgerinnen
mitbürger insbesondere in den
intensivstationen der krankenhäuser aber
wir müssen unsere arbeit unter diesen
bedingungen machen
deswegen haben wir damals schon gesagt
im plenum abstand und wer im plenarsaal
selbst kein platz also in den reihen der
abgeordneten aber die zuschauertribünen
dafür freigehalten
sie sind dazu herzlich eingeladen
bleibst zu nehmen sie nehmen da genauso
an der debatte teil
und sie brauchen keine stehplätze haben
wenn sie stehen müssen sie im übrigen
mund nasen abdeckung tragen aber es wäre
mir lieber sie würden von dem angebot
gebrauch machen da oben wie einige
kollegen jetzt schon platz zu nehmen so
jetzt hat als letzter redner zur
geschäftsordnung letzte rednerin das
wort die kollegin britta haßelmann
bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte damen und herren sehr
geehrter herr präsident ich frage mich
gerade ob ich abwarten soll bis ihre
aufforderung folge geleistet wird
[Applaus]
[Musik]
naja ich bin jetzt sieht ja jede und
jeder dass es genügend kollegen gibt der
afg fraktion die sich nicht an die
aufforderung des bundestagspräsidenten
halten die sich einen teufel darum
scheren ob sie andere kolleginnen und
kollegen in gefahr bringt dem risiko
aussetzen einer neuinfektion und einer
ansteckung und ich halte das für
verantwortungslos auch dass wir die
allgemeinverfügung noch nicht
ausgeweitet haben dahingehend dass auch
am platz masken tragen ist meine damen
und herren
diese abgeordneten gefährden die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter dieses
hauses und sie gefährten anderer
abgeordneten kolleginnen und kollegen
und das finde ich unerträglich blues
sache meine damen und herren
der vorliegende geschäftsordnungsantrag
ist nichts anderes als heuchelei
es geht der afg fraktion nicht um die
sache auch zwei wochen längere
beratungszeit würde nicht dazu führen
dass irgend ein substanzieller
inhaltlicher beitrag von der rechten
seite des hauses käme
meine damen und herren die situation ist
viel zu ernst sie ist dramatisch der
bundestag hat eingefordert dass wir
bundeseinheitliche regelungen treffen
der bundestag hat mehrmals gefordert
dass das parlament entscheidungen trifft
und die sind zeitnah zu treffen weil die
infektions lage weil die situation auf
den intensivstationen in den
krankenhäusern dramatisch ist und das
hat uns in dieser woche in diesem
beratungsverfahren all den kollegin
verdammt viel abverlangt abverlangt
dadurch dass wir uns in der sache in den
ausschüssen dauernd damit beschäftigt
haben und auch sehr kurzfristig damit
beschäftigt haben das war schwierig und
das war eine belastbare situation aber
die belastung für die menschen die im
gesundheitswesen arbeiten die täglich
ihren dienst tun die menschen davor
schützen dass sie in gefahr geraten in
noch größerer ansteckungsgefahr
die ist wesentlich größer und deshalb
sage ich ihnen hören sie auf zu jammern
arbeiten sie hinhalten ich meine damen
und herren
da haben sie denn ich nichts zu sagen
anders als alle anderen fraktionen und
begeht es hier geht es nicht um die
sache dagegen wir gleich waren sie nicht
in der lage inhaltliche beiträge zu
liefern und ich weiß woran das liegt wer
keine position zu der korona pandemie
hat heute leugnet morgen die masken
pflicht ablehnt und übermorgen sich mit
werden könnte mein hut hat halt keinen
inhaltlichen beitrag zu liefern
meine damen und herren
den antrag ab es ist viel zeit
verstrichen
wir hätten viel schneller entscheiden
müssen das wäre der situation angemessen
und ich bin froh dass wir heute gegen
debatte führen und endlich entscheiden
was sind wochen und monate verstrichen
in dem der bundestag seine aufgabe hätte
schon wahrnehmen müssen danken so britta
haßelmann war die letzte im reigen der
parlamentarischen geschäftsführerin und
geschäftsführer und jetzt wird über den
antrag der afg abgestimmt mit den
genannten änderungen und ergänzungen
wer stimmte für er stimmte dagegen
er enthält sich dann ist die
tagesordnung gegen die stimmen der afc
so beschlossen